people don't want to be classy at all
period because they want to
just get the clicks you know what I'm
saying it's all about relevance like
after this R Cat Williams [__] the guy's
got the highest selling [__] now Tour
all of his stuff is back on the
algorithm and everything it's crazy all
because he just talk [__] A bunch about
a bunch of people and like where where I
hate when people say this but like where
I come from and I don't mean like
physically and geologically but like in
my mind State like unloading the clip on
a bunch of [__] and like doing
it just to get clips is is it's so
whack to
me because it's
like you do [__] up [__] too you
know I don't
know dude how funny was it that Cory hul
said the thing about stealing jokes was
hilarious oh it was so funny dude let's
see if I can look it up Cory hul come K
went on Club sha Shay where a lot of
[__] got to explain [__] if you
stole jokes you stole jokes listen 90%
of comedians steal jokes cat stole JB
smooth joke and did it on his special
it's the joke with the music too many
Comics know what I'm saying is straight
I stole a joke before this the truth I
stole a [__] from Columbus Ohio joke
the [__] name was Stephen G my people
basically borrow and they kind of like
no it's not borrowing I stole this joke
I got stuck one day and I remember his
joke and I did it and they paid me $500
so Stephen G get up with me homie I'mma
give you 500 plus interest I swear this
the truth I took a [__] joke before we
can't have a [__] just telling
on everybody if you ain't F to stand on
who you are if you a [__] who telling
on [__] and putting everybody else
[__] out there and you be doing the same
[__] ain't nobody going to respect you
they going to be like oh hell no [__]
you everybody you be doing that [__] you
get what I'm saying so that's what I'm
trying to say if you really going to be
the shepherd of men we going to step
back and respect you cuz you polarizing
my [__] [__] love C Williams he a
little [__] all them little [__]
people like him my [__] cat listen you
could stand up and be something that
people really [__] be like okay
but see you also got to remember us
[__] in the comedy streets I'm glad
that cat went on
that's funny bro that made me
laugh cuz it make CU it's like
dude wow that made me
laugh it is it is weird though like
that's what I dude there was a I had a
[__] when I I I had this girlfriend a
long time ago uh I must have been 35 or
something I can't even remember and I
was I I I I I had like cheated on her
and uh an another comic was K well he's
not even a comic he was an actor turn
comic that was trying to do standup now
because his career was failing but he
was like uh he was like
um met her and she he was like who do
you go out who you go out with she's
like I go out with a comic and she's
like crystalia and he was like oh he
cheats like Ju Just know that and I'm
like
like first of all that's bit [__] it's
it's number one it's it's shitty to do
period like let people do their business
I guess but
like that I could forgive it if it was
like you're not that type of guy and
you're like all right you know what dude
I I want to let you know like I feel
like this is the right thing to do I can
understand that but what I can't
understand is you he does it to worse
more so it's like if you do it more or
the same don't call out another
[__] for being a bad person for
doing that [__] when you're just trying
to do it to to [__] her you know what
I'm saying that is the worst and you
dudes know what I'm talking about with
these [__]
right God those are the worst guys those
are the worst
guys and I this I can't stand this dude
he's the worst and every time he sees me
he's like hey what's up and I'm like
hey God
you can guess who it is but I don't want
to I don't want to dox him or anything